cries out to the graves of her 25 year
old twin sons lang wang and thapuang she
pleads with them to come home for
christmas
the brothers from outing village in mon
district were in this pickup truck last
saturday when soldiers opened fire six
of the eight coal miners traveling with
them were shot dead
cognac led a search party when the
miners failed to return home after we
we came to know that the bodies are
there
some of my
friends those who came along with me
we started
they started
setting fire to three vehicles
and after that
i went down there and i was sitting
there
and then we all
they all started firing and i lay down
and stayed there
following the ambush another seven men
were killed when soldiers fired at
protesting villages another protester
was killed the following day
india's home minister said the soldiers
were acting on intelligence that rebels
were on the road adding that the
government regretted the incident
during the ambush a vehicle approached
the location and it was signaled to stop
however it tried to flee
following which the vehicle suspected of
carrying insurgents was fired upon
resulting in the killing of six out of
the eight traveling in it however it
turned out to be a case of mistaken
identity
but one of the two survivors told al
jazeera the truck driver was never asked
to stop by troops who fired from both
the front and back
son sean wang was the truck driver
they were ambushed they shot innocent
people who didn't know anything it
wasn't even at night or in the jungle it
was on the road in broad daylight
the killings have provoked protests
against the armed forces special powers
act which gives the military extended
powers in areas where rebels are
operating the afsbah law is enforced in
india-administered kashmir and large
parts of india's north-eastern states
soldiers have the power to shoot to kill
arrest without warrant or destroy
suspect buildings all with immunity from
prosecution as far must go and why
aspire is bad that is the recent example
14 innocent
indian
citizen indigenous people of nagaland
were killed by armed forces
we cannot accept we cannot tolerate
we are no second to citizen how does
government of india can kill the
innocent
civilian of the country
government leaders say the army needs
extra powers in regions where rebels
operate but as the week-long mourning
for the villages of outing goes on
nagaland and meghalaya state leaders are
appealing to their government ally the
bharatiya janta party to repeal the
contentious shoot to kill law
elizabeth paranam al jazeera new delhi